screen junkies studios in the heart of
Los Angeles this is screen junkies movie
finds now your host Andy signor hello
screen junkies Wow I cannot tell you how
excited I am for today's fight you guys
are in for such a treat in honor of the
upcoming film cooties which looks
awesome and comes out Friday available
in theaters and on demand this Friday we
have an amazing special guest today I'm
just gonna go right to him it's Elijah
Wood hi guys what thanks for coming dude
dude thank you for having me I'm excited
you I we we've been already talking
movies with you I'm so impressed with
your knowledge I think these two guys
are gonna get very nervous very fast
because you are cleared not just a
famous person you know your movies and I
like watching movies yes I just can
vouch I'm I love this guy already come
on sometimes celebrities show up and
they don't know their movies I'm call I
want everyone to know you're you're the
real deal thank you thank you for being
here and thank you for being the real
deal and it's my pleasure we brought two
vicious competitors here and a slew of
elijah themed topics not for us to fight
today you always need them out by the
way for you okay so we have to be there
I don't want talk about Elijah non-stop
but that's just my own way today we're
gonna debate best fantasy franchise best
Lord of the Rings movie funniest horror
movie so many fun things are gonna watch
so stay tuned and as always if you're
watching on YouTube and you don't like
something click the bottom right hand
corner and you can skip ahead to any of
our fights you don't have to just leave
the show don't leave Elijah woods here
you're not gonna leave but don't skip
forward all it's all gonna be
entertaining yes but everything we say
is hilarious today generation that
sometimes they don't
can we get to something interesting as
always you know we're in iTunes please
subscribe us there but I want to get
right to this so he's here you know I'm
from Lord of the Rings eternal sunshine
of spotless mind Sin City the ice storm
the faculty the good Sun the war radio
flare North Deep Impact Happy Feet
Wilford the Oxford murders grand piano
and the upcoming cooties which is coming
up Friday which looks fantastic on VOD
and in theaters it's Elijah Wood bye
guys
we're happy to have you here I'm happy
no pressure these guys are graft for
blood let's meet them Dan Merle yes
screen junkies insider resident champion
and guys and good guys maybe we'll see
I'm honest trailers writer producer Dan
Merle hi this is this is this is crazy
so you have to this is insane
next to him I'm a good sport you know
he's our resident fixer fixer he's an
actor and friend with with the rock so
be careful Hardy boy and party boy that
dick Fundy yes
pleasure meeting you I'm back - good son
you all over the place sweet and by good
sunning me are you gonna be hanging me
from a cliff the side of a cliff and
decide which one Falls yes okay to help
us here in case anyone gets their facts
misconstrued we have a leash I'm alone
on the fat chicken care hey Alicia how
fun is this episode already I want to
say I'm saying Elijah Wood and a
fantastic fest debates which not only
constitutes a debate but also a
fistfight so Dan Nick bass game we're
not garbage but again you're proving he
knows his stuff and I'm happy to have
I'm so happy to have you here
rules reminder as I told you ahead of
time this is about the argument so it's
not just about why yours is the best
it's about why theirs isn't
hmm makes sense any questions before we
begin no questions all right let's do it
let's do it
[Applause]
aha that's so great get us ready alright
round one in honor of cooties switch
again I want to I want guys
Elijah woods here do you know what that
means go download cooties for real go do
a cooties movie on Twitter and go check
out this movie I haven't actually been
able to see it yet but the trailer looks
awesome I love funny movies and love
zombie movies I love how this movie's
looks awesome how fun was it to make
super from Rainn Wilson right yet Alison
Pill Nasim pedrad early from war that's
right it was written by Leigh Whannell
who wrote sawn insidious and it was
co-written by Ian Brennan who was a
creator of Glee so it was like the Hoos
brought to you by the creators of Glee
and song that's pretty awesome it's very
very funny
it's also really scary too I think it
was always important for us to like keep
the balance of those things occurring
throughout the entire film so I think
it's entertaining on all levels
children come on yes right they get
cooties and it's actually like a zombie
it's a virus that affects children only
pre-puberty like cooties yeah I can't
wait a mintue savages that we never have
to have children no support your argue
please go support check it out in honor
of the movie we wanted to ask this
because that movie looks really funny
and fun we wouldn't ask for round one
what's the funniest horror movie of all
time
funniest hard movie of all time and
Elijah we're gonna start with you what's
your chick what's your choice Shaun of
the Dead oh do I make my argument yes oh
that's that's when that happens all
right give us a little intro Shaun of
the Dead it as far as horror comedy is
concerned this one's far more skewing on
the comedy side of things I think Edgar
Wright is brilliant I think some Pegg is
brilliant I'm I'm very attuned to and
loved British comedy it's got this sort
of it's it's very dry humor but the
scenarios are insane as well so it's
like this sort of juxtaposition against
how crazy the world is but it's also
emotional it's about friendship it's a
it's essentially a parable that uses the
sort of zombie milieu to tell its story
and I think it's
a piece of brilliant filmmaking okay
he's thrown out words like parable and
medium dan what's your pick funniest
hard movie I mean listen it's tough to
top Shaun of the Dead if you know me
you'll know that that's that's really
difficult for me point oz yes but it
doesn't matter
no I didn't I think that that Shaun of
the Dead exists because of a movie that
preceded it that Edgar Wright has often
put in his top 10 best movies of all
time and that's Evil Dead 2 directed by
Sam Raimi and when you talk about funny
horror movies Evil Dead 2 kind of
perfected that because it is equal parts
of both it's not more one of the one of
more than the other I don't think and it
really did inspire a generation of
filmmakers like Edgar Wright to to
realize that if you want to make a
horror movie you don't have to be put in
that box that you can you can do both
you can do it well I mean at launch
bruce campbell as a very unlikely horror
movie icon and it's proof that you don't
need all the resources in the world to
make a really solid funny movie and i
think that there is a generation of
filmmakers including Edgar Wright that
saw that and built on that foundation
and wasn't we're inspired by that movie
and said I can do what I want to do
because he did it Wow
these are some strong choices out the
gate I'm Nick I'm sure gonna bring a
good one what are you pickin well I look
at horror and I think of many things you
think of people getting stabbed and
killed I like to think of horror as
people who come together to make
something so terrible something so so
shitty just something something such a
cash grab that it just it brings horror
to the eyes of everyone who's seen it
like the audience is viscerally watching
horror before them and not just made up
[ __ ] but like man man's hubris horror
and that's why I picked Jason X 2002's
Jason X by the way it's hilarious too
because they couldn't even get to the
rights to the Friday the 13th name they
had to call it Jason X is that true yes
it was not Friday the 13th Jason I know
it was Jason X get out yeah there was a
choice though no no no no they okay
here's the thing this song has let the
bodies hit the floor song played four
times throughout the movie
this is this how terrible and hilarious
the song is it's like I watching a bad
sci-fi channel movie with an eleven
million dollar budget this month movie
had money they it was no how they defeat
Jason they do a hologram of Crystal Lake
to distract him and they keep that going
and then the movie ends
yes movies hilarious it's terrible
it's horrible it's a horror upon our
eyes and guys let the bodies hit the
floor let the bodies hit the floor with
Jason max by the way if you're not
familiar with it it's the one where he
goes into space yeah he's in space he
also has a metal mask yeah no heat
transfer why the hell does he have a
metal Mairs
you know what this movies did was like
hey you know that terrible Resident Evil
movie we should do a Jason movie like
that's what that that's what movie did
so your guys movies are pretend horror
this is an actual [ __ ] well we're at a
very different level you're saying that
the the making of the film is is
horrific
yes so therefore it is the sense of
horror yeah we are we are saying that
our the films we're advocating for our
actual horror movies where mine is a
horror upon the earth it's like another
horror is what you refer that yeah where
mine is just a crime against nature it's
just it's a strike against the world
you have a real animosity toward the
horror genre don't you no no because I
watch it follows because my wife told me
to watch it and it was quite good and I
watch babadook and I'd never want to
have kids again so alright so on topic
[ __ ] yes sorry what do you guys think
what about the other choices here listen
Jason axe is a brilliant masterpiece of
something gone horribly wrong so it's a
tough one good you know if we're if
we're if we look at Shaun of the Dead
objectively it's a very funny movie and
intentionally so so I stick with that
what Jason X is great it's a tough one I
just have a rebuttal to it is a very bad
film it's unintentionally funny so I
would demote you were if I was gonna try
and argue this I would I
would demote it for not being
intentionally funny
it is accidentally funny and I'll think
about that well listen this is also very
hard which is round one I know I think
Evil Dead 2 is is terribly funny yes it
did you know pave the way for other
filmmakers to make movies in of its ilk
I would also say that Peter Jackson's
bad taste and brain dead are very much
in that same category
what's my [ __ ] argument again yeah
well yeah Nick yeah yours is yours is I
would also demote it because it's
unintentionally funny guys on the street
in the middle if a guy slips on the
middle of the street
you're gonna laugh because it's funny
sure accidental funny funny funny is
funny it doesn't matter like funny it's
funny if Andy fell out of it and nobody
wants to be a part of it right but it's
but it's parading itself as a strict
straight horror movie you don't know
it's a little ridiculous no it's not
watch do you think no did when he
freezes the body in the ministrations
ooh come on since 2002 they were not
self-aware here's the thing it's not
that's poison acts could chase into
space of course it was self-aware
alright you've made that point what
about the other two though why what's
the that I demote yours because it's
just a bad movie yes you laugh at a bad
movie but I think when you talk about
funnies you have to you have to look at
the craft you have to look at the you
know comedy and horror and not to genre
so that should go together so I think
you have to kind of give a tip of the
hat at least to the two that were able
to blend them intentionally and well and
yeah and done you know our Captain exact
I just never was scared of your movies
and I'm not scared of yours well I think
I think would make an argument for Evil
Dead 2 that it actually is scary because
of how gory that film is so I think if
you if I became if you're a new if
you're new to the horror genre and you
saw that film and you were sensitive to
really gory films that
could that can I the comedy I don't know
would necessarily like write that off I
think it's a it's a tough move because
it's really bloody yeah and pretty
frightening well your bring it right
background Shaun of the Dead is there's
craftsmanship in that in that
storytelling sure you could make the
argument that it was inspired by and
certainly Evil Dead to pave the way for
it but it's it's a very beautifully
crafted film I think the thing I love
about Edgar right and and the sort of
Coronado trilogy is that each of those
stories is about something that that
it's not about zombies it's not about
robots from space these films they're
about growing up about you know the sort
of human issues present that film Shaun
of the Dead is about a guy who refuses
to grow up his girlfriend's gonna leave
in and it's set against the world of
zombies in such a brilliant way so I
think the craftsmanship present in that
film is why I would I would sort of
argue that's the best sure and I mean
deeply funny building on that might
might and I don't want to call it a
knock but my arguing against China the
dead is that and all the colleges is
that they do use the genre more as a
framing device for telling a story as
opposed to like making it an actual
genre picture whereas I think evil that
too is much closer to an actual horror
genre picture with comedy elements so I
think it's of the three I think it's the
purest horror comedy of the three last
thoughts Nick I think both good movies
so it's hard to argue but what's the
most horrific movie mine what's the
funniest movie mine
alright calling it Alisha anything to
add on your enemy the fact that made you
guys have to part you Jason already all
the facts were clean I just wanted to
point out so Jason X was conceived when
Freddy vs. Jason was in development hell
they decided to put it in space because
they wanted to set it after the events
of the future battle so it sounds like
they weren't that self-aware because
they wanted to take inspiration from
alien and aliens and make horror in
space that's amazing
Wow they either succeeded every all the
spectacular that's incredible one base
failure is their success it's it's our
success you mean you had a very
interesting point but sadly it's between
these two Nick based on the arguments I
think Elijah helped you a little bit and
then the last point that just because
there don't know how you picked between
those two but it was basically the fact
that yours is more of a genuine horror
movie that's what I'm gonna go after
Evil Dead 2 and Dan Morell get the first
point of the show Sharla that's my
favorite movie
so really Dan loses rap to this might be
the most important debate of them all we
couldn't imagine a more fitting guest to
help us settle it so Mira's elder on on
Twitter the Steve 1996 on Twitter asked
us what's the best French sorry what's
the best fantasy franchise of all time
now to make this easier we've whittled
down to you can either choose Lord of
the Rings Harry Potter Star Wars or Game
of Thrones and Dan you get to lead with
this one and which one would you pick oh
this is kind of weird
I chose Lord of the Rings I think it is
the best I mean not just movie wise
which is what we'll debate but I think
that's a side note just like in
literature the best Fantasy franchise
ever and side note we love yes I love
all these franchises but yeah I think
Lord of the Rings as far as movie
fantasy goes is the standard-bearer
because movie fantasy had kind of like I
don't and we'll get into it a little bit
more I don't really consider Star Wars
pure fantasy and Lord of the Rings I
think was the first pure fantasy
franchise and that proved that it was
cinematically viable to do fantasy
movies because it was so hit or miss and
spotty before that so that's why I
choosing with rings and I'm sure we will
have much more debate to follow Nick
what are you picking I'm picking Star
Wars the original the like if Star Wars
didn't come out you wouldn't have Lord
of the Rings you wouldn't have Game of
Thrones you wouldn't have Harry Potter
because what it did was took sci-fi and
fantasy elements and made it and
westerns yeah and Western and made it
massively appealing to all people all
associate economic groups
everyone loves Star Wars it doesn't
matter who you are
doesn't matter if you're a jock nerd
geek I'm just using a t term spaz avoid
dork doing
preppy every every 80s comedy trope and
love Star Wars it's just the movie that
like my dad has never read a sci-fi book
in the world he knows everything about
Star Wars my brother like will never
watch a comic movie he's obsessed with
Star Wars like Star Wars is the thing
that brings people together minor league
baseball teams have Star Wars night they
have you know I mean it's the beyond
just the movies it's the most like the
biggest pop culture hit like ever I mean
it's it's Star Wars it's why like in a
couple of months it's gonna make two
billion dollars it's Star Wars is what
made all everything else happen and it's
and it's Star and it's Star Wars is it
Star Wars Nick you're a Best Fantasy
franchise of all time I'm gonna choose
out of that list Game of Thrones
I couldn't rightfully choose Lord of the
Rings it just feels wrong and I have to
challenge myself a little bit but no I
think Game of Thrones is extraordinary I
think it has raised the bar for
television I think it's raised the bar
for fantasy storytelling
I think what's extraordinary about it is
that it's it presents itself as a very
real world atmosphere and environment
you believe that these people existed
much like Lord of the Rings the they
don't lead with fantasy it's really
about these characters and it's about
the politics involved it's very
emotionally engaging as a show the its
its ability to and certainly from the
books its ability to sort of kill off
main characters is terrifying and you
you always sort of feel this sense of
unease it's just great storytelling it's
great political storytelling that
happens to have dragons I just think
it's extraordinary
Dan back to you to get some points well
they both have the same viewpoint on
Sean Bean apparently we don't know
what's happening in episode first of all
to say that to say that there'd be no
lore of the Rings without Star Wars yes
Lord of the Rings existed way before
star wars movies and and I disagree like
George Lucas well you know what to make
Lord of the Rings for years and years
and years trying to get the rights to
that Kubrick wanted to make
- apparently yeah the Beatles if you
believe but check that because that
definitely exists oh I've heard that
effort that I know right so III just I
disagree wholeheartedly that lor the
Rings movie even the movies wouldn't
exist without stars because because Star
Wars doesn't really share anything in
common with Lord of the Rings
it made nerd [ __ ] cool for a mass like a
massive amount of people well there was
like there was like 30 years in between
III don't know I think it add more if I
may I think it had more to do with the
time being appropriate for being able to
have the resources to tell the story
right not that there was a not an
audience for it because the book the
audience for the book is massive
yeah massive I mean in the 70s like
there were pins Frodo lives like it was
a huge like hippie subculture thing so I
think it had more to do with and you
said it's not right massively popular
subcultures but like honestly I never
read Lord of the Rings before you didn't
think it was acid you bit quetesh you
know no and Star Wars was that was that
thing that like it just it brings
everyone together everyone's a fan of
Star Wars everyone was a fan of Star
well okay that's the other thing
Star Wars is a thing that brings people
together not anymore it's a thing that
tears people talk about The Hobbit maybe
it's because I'm trying to nor the
Hobbit well it's not part of my face so
it doesn't matter the other part another
thing is the prequels are part of your
franchise
well they are part of the same story and
that's that that's where unfortunately
argument holds less water because that
is a pretty massive blight on yeah but
dude like how I mean all I gotta say is
and where the chlorines do the chlorines
and and and suddenly okay but suddenly
r2d2 can fly when did he have that
ability and then loose it was time for
what with army what was the 5th army so
wait now a judge judge movies part of
much of my know what they are not
technically a part of they're not
hobby moves jibber-jabber you are
discussing way more in my head but the
prequels are part of yours do count so
you know that because it's a part of the
same as you know and you know people are
so disappointed about the prequels
they're still dying to see force awakens
and they're still excited about these
spin-offs and they're doing people are
going nuts about Star Wars that it's
only it's only because they have started
to see that it's in the right hands
again that's where the rings we haven't
gone know I want to make the argument
that there wouldn't be a game of Thrones
without Lord of the Rings because I
think they're very similar i think
george RR martin I looked it up as even
said he Revere's Lord of the Rings he
reads it all the time so I think it
would be is that why he's not writing
any more books so I do I would find it
hard to believe that there wasn't an
influence but beyond that if we're
talking about just the works the the
public they filmed works III like Game
of Thrones I think it's it's a very
engaging show it's much more of a first
of all we don't know how it ends this is
a little tough to judge it on a whole
and secondly like I think it's much been
Lord of the Rings and her personal it's
still going on yeah the extended version
we can talk about this later and I think
we actually will III think that Lord the
Rings just stands more alone and is such
a Titan that so many things builds upon
that's why it kind of takes that place
at the top for me how was the Hobbit not
part of Lord of the Rings because it was
never written first time it was written
as a single standalone book no Jay wrote
for his son as like a sort of adventure
story and then he was approached by the
publisher to write a sequel and he
refused to do it and then ultimately
conceived of the idea for Lord of the
Rings movies are the three minutes I
think you should trust the lines of
Mecca season 2 of Game of Thrones wasn't
I'm finding it difficult to challenge
your statements about Game of Thrones
cuz you're right I mean part of it is
the approach to the thing the thing
about Lord of the Rings I'm really fail
this debate thing but the thing about
Lord of the Rings is that that what made
that movie so unique in the in the
landscape of fantasy is its approach the
fact that it approached it very
seriously it took the character
seriously it was not it didn't feel like
a typical fantasy movie but it had all
the elements of a fantasy film just like
star you really cared about the
characters and and and again it the
world felt real and I think that's why
Game of Thrones is as successful as it
is because it feels real and it and
there's weight to it and you care about
who these people are so I can't really I
can't disagree with you I would like to
say I mean - the prequel garbage which
is a part of it but you know all
relationships have their ups and downs
Star Wars felt real I mean it was like
the first sci-fi thing Star Trek didn't
hit as big as like Star Wars like I've
never understood Star Trek em either
[Laughter]
franchise it was the first Fantasy
franchise that just exploded and I to me
well hold on that's a kind of good for
the sake of time I do again we listen we
can't waste our words is great I need to
know why its way toward you like exactly
like I know but why aren't these two
things as good as Star Wars is what I'm
trying to get out of you because Star
Wars was first and it's still bigger
it's still just told you it wasn't first
so the books were before Star Wars we're
talking last thoughts from you two
before I make the ruling is I feel like
I heard it but anything you want to add
alright I just wanted to say it's true
that Stanley Kubrick was approached by
the Beatles
make a version of Lord of the Rings
after Tolkien sold the rights in 1969
but Kubrick said to John Lennon it can't
be done cooperate so Lennon that I would
love to listen that guy isn't that
incredible they're there unless it's
been the weirdest Lord of the Rings film
I think he wanted I think Lennon wanted
to play Gollum which makes total sense
so you just think about their
personalities who most let's see some
posters I think Paul wanted to do
to be Gandalf Frank Sinatra and I think
I think Ringo was gonna be Samwise
alright based on the we could talk all
day I'm trying to keep our show on all
right so based on the arguments between
the prequels we don't know what happens
in the end and the fact that you did
prove that lor the Rings did come before
Star Wars I got to give it to Dan again
that's two points for Dan I thought we
talked about the movies that was that
was near the top of lead just surreal
moments in my life right there trying to
convince Elijah Wood that Lord of the
Rings we don't know where it ends all
right
round three junior Tolkien it has
written many wonderful characters and
more specifically many wonderful Hobbit
characters so being at this is movie
fight we won't thought we'd ask this fun
question what Hobbit would win in a
battle royale for the One Ring so you
can pick any Hobbit from any of the
films we are gonna count both of them
now if you could pick one Hobbit who
would win in a battle Royales of death
to get that one ring we're starting with
you Nick I have a slightly controversial
thing that I want to add here yes sure I
love Connor I made a choice but there
was another idea that I have that I that
was not included that you all didn't
think about oh okay you can call it when
we get to you okay let's go with Nick
first all right to me this one's easy
it's pip pip loves drugs right he loves
smoking pipe weed yeah he likes drinkin
this dude is gonna get high as [ __ ] not
feel pain drink hallucinate and then
just kill all of his friends and he
won't feel anything because he loves
drugs like he's gonna freak out just
start ripping your throat out he's gonna
rip Sam's throw it out and porn you
you're Sam he's just gonna start ripping
throats out cuz he can't feel anything
all he's gonna fail is the power of
drugs coursing through his body
love is a battle all he cared about was
getting high and getting drunk well
guess what during a battle royale he's
gonna do both and to start ripping
throats and winning and then throats man
and then on the he's gonna love this
method he's gonna stand on top of his
friends bodies in a pile in a friend
pile cold in the rain yeah holding the
ring up Tory
he's gonna smoke out of it smoke out of
that ring how would that work magic
alright Elijah let's hear a
controversial pick sneagle
he was a hobbit before Gollum you said
yes yes yes
so are we allowing that judges choice so
yeah he was a hobbit before he was he
was corrupted by the ring physically
there is absolutely no question that his
desire and madness as a result of having
this relationship with the ring it's it
was enough to turn him evil to where all
he could think about his entire being
was about getting this ring back so he
would stop at nothing to kill and he's
got an alter ego which is his madness
and that's Gollum Gollum has no there's
no sense of humanity left in that
character whatever ounce of Smeagol that
still exists is ruined by the ring so he
would absolutely win in a battle you
know what's more corrupting corruptive
than the One Ring drugs well one could
say that the ring itself is a drug that
affects the the one who holds it very
much like a drug does so is drugs who
are you picking Danny no the battle I
would call I'll stick with the I'll
stick with Frodo sure I'll stick with
Frodo I'll say Frodo this needs to be
bizarre
first of all Pippin he liked mushrooms
and pipeweed that doesn't make you start
ripping people's throats out he's gonna
be staring at the wall or never had a
bad bad no bad batch of mushrooms turned
you turned your violin rippen monster
okay so anything I but I do not gonna be
coordinated happy guys you never would
99 remember Woodstock 99 they're all on
mushrooms yeah I just don't I don't
think Pippin is gonna be in fighting
shape if that's all right so you got
Smeagol and Frodo and I mean I feel like
we've seen this fight and I don't know I
thought it was if there wasn't a lava
pit there I think that fight would have
gone on a little bit longer and probably
I think between the two
I'm going with with Frodo I think he's a
little more agile I think he's a little
more useful that nine-fingered pansy he
got his finger bit off I'm assuming this
takes place after the movies I don't
know when it takes place it's very
hypothetical argument yeah
it could literally take place right
there it could if they hadn't been which
case in which case Pippin has wandered
off the edge and into the lava because
he's high on mushrooms and pipe weed and
drunk shower down to Smeagol and Frodo
this is how gang fights work the first
guy you go after is the craziest one
Smeagol is the first one dead he's like
because they're all going out oh you
think he's the crazy no they're gonna
really gonna go for the girl yeah
they're gonna just start ripping arms
off yeah you go for Smeagol you knock
him out because he's the wild card and
then you go for Frodo cuz he's the one
friendships are important know you then
you go Sam then you go Frodo because
Frodo doesn't have Sam backing them up
and then there's me he loses his side
man he's after yeah right and then you
got married Pippin Gill guess what
Pippin ty he's super hot you're really
going with this whole thing like that's
gonna be super helpful and it is but I'm
kind of I'm with you I think that is
very uncoordinated yeah he'd be like
staring down into the pit distracted
really easily and Mike ever see somebody
high look at a lava lamp imagine that
but it's everything yeah ecstasy Eagle
you said that you think he's agile
Frodo's agile and I think swingles far
more agile he's like a he's like a
spider he's a creature he can climb on
walls see he's difficult to catch I
think he plays a really interesting game
which is this game of manipulation he
can appear to be trustworthy and I think
that's something that he would use to
his advantage around what does it mean
to lava nobodies scrappier and more
deadly than Smeagol AKA golem i like how
you said royal not know i mean i again i
thinks we go lets me go throws me for a
loop doesn't i think all bets are off I
think it's just a 50/50
throwdown I'm just going with a hunch
that I think you know Smeagol is little
you know he's kind of wasted away a
little bit and I think all it takes is
one slip-up and Frodo's got it I think
he's gotten a brute strength not where I
thought it would go but still fun I had
made googling magic mushroom violence
apparently if you have a bad trip you
can turn violent really but I don't know
trust me I'm gonna say this one's tough
but I think they did school you pretty
well I think he'd be distracted by that
llama they're totally right so that
argument they still gonna what stuck so
I'm between Smeagol photo and it was
really 5050 but that was the last point
he had really took him over the edge so
Elijah gets the point yeah he would be
difficult to catch it's a good point and
we didn't even think of him when we
brought up our list so early he's all
tied you get the point
that's two to one Dan and Elijah Wow
Nick you're getting on the board
hopefully around four should be
interesting now we all know if you
Jackson's Lord we shall G cinematic
masterpiece we all agree they're all
awesome films we're really on a load of
the Rings sort of which our world learns
Brock can we go back weird what is the
best film from the Lord the Rings
trilogy
that's our fight here now we are
starting back to you Elijah what is the
best film if you had to pick one from
the trilogy what's the best I think it's
unquestionably Fellowship of the Ring
it's the most balanced of the three it's
where we're introduced to the notion of
the fellowship it's where we see them
before they break off as a unit working
together for the ultimate goal of
destroying this ring we spend time
initially in Hobbiton there's a
beautiful prologue that introduces us to
the history of the ring it's just the
most evenly balanced film it's an
introduction to all these characters we
fall in love with these characters and
ultimately we're taking on a much darker
journey as the story progresses but I
feel like it just in terms of because
the thing that a lot of people argue
about the film's as they carry on as
they get longer and longer
the extended cuts whilst I love them
delve into elements that aren't
necessarily right for theatrical edit
they're a little big they're a little
bloated in a good way
this is the tightest it's the tightest
of the three it's the one that works as
a complete film in its best form dan
what are you picking I'm going with the
finale I'm going with the turn of the
King only because I think that there are
certainly great seeds planted in the
first and second movies but I think it
all pays off and the third movie I think
really the moment for me when it paid
off
is the the moment when they says you
bout no one which me was the emotional
payoff of the whole trilogy and it's
kind of the whole thing coming full
circle the small guys are now the big
guys so to speak and you know I know
that there are knocks on Return of the
King you did multiple endings and
everything that never really bothered me
it's it's the ending to a very long
story I don't mind that that you got to
I don't pay everything off and I just
think that that you know the first two
are great films but they would be
diminished a little bit if the if the
payoff wasn't there and I think that it
was so hard to pay off both of those
movies there's so much pressure it's the
one that one finally the Best Picture
Oscar and you know for me it's the one
that you know it just hits that that
emotional punch that's kind of been
building up for now all tio2 movies so
that's why I go through turn to the king
Nick yeah but first I'm gonna be cool if
we were talking like five questions
about deep impact like which I would be
doubtful what does le stand did you
really two towers know oh my god I love
to tap like look I love all these movies
I never read the books but two towers
for me is what like hit me as a young 20
year old it's the most action-packed and
it has some boss helms deep is one of
the coolest action sequences I've ever
seen and it's like 30 minutes long and
it never gets old and like you feel like
you're in it like you're exhausted at
the end of that movie and it's just
wonderful and beautiful and you're
probably writing well the third act The
Return of the King action sequences
wasn't you know
nothing compares to that don't don't
worry about it what I love about this is
yeah the first movie introduced these
characters this is the one we where they
split up he actually spend time with
them you get to know Eragon you get to
know at Legolas you get to spend more
time with Elijah which was just aces for
me no um the the most important thing
that this movie did was introduce
Smeagol Gollum and it was the it was
like insane to see this digital
character something that was ruined by
Jar Jar Binks and then the the weird elf
got in a hurry Potter but like you saw
this full character and it was like like
that was the groundbreaking cinema right
there was that character and I just feel
like it's the tightest it I think it's
the tightest I think it's most
action-packed
I think that has the most character
growth and no I mean and there's no
Eagles I think it's just I think it's
great and also I got laid the night I
saw it so I mean I all of this well
that's what this is a special place it's
the movie I've watched more I've watched
two towers more than I've watched any of
them ow yeah oh yeah no you watch the
middle chapter more than the first
because you know what it holds up just
by itself and like I'm the big action
movie guy and it sounds like the Empire
Strikes Back yes
yeah I think in a way it kind of is I
mean it's very much the middle it's the
darkest I think of the three it is but I
think it's like these guys are going to
put an end on no but what happened with
Return of the King I don't think it paid
off like oh they did like we didn't get
to see any Eragon in that movie barely
an Aragorn they're gone yeah well on a
vera thorne get it right I know
like it just didn't pay off the like the
effects in a Return of the King were not
nearly as good it felt rushed it felt
know like the elephants and like Legolas
look very matrix e digital carrot Alec
I'm nitpicking but like because they're
all great but lay slides on his shield
in two towers lest you forget yeah and
it looked awesome well it did alright
yeah what action Fellowship is great but
it feels like a prequel to two towers
which is like the meat um yeah I don't I
don't I don't entirely agree the
question was
what's the best sequence in all three
movies there might be a fight for helms
deep because that is certainly a great
battle it really is um but it there's a
bigger battle in three which i think is
just as good if not better it's choppy
and and I also think that you know again
for me personally as good as Holmes deep
is just on a personal level you know two
towers has the stuff that I'm the least
interested in when I was reading and
also watching the movies which is merry
and pippin in the force has never really
grabbed me and so that's the movie that
I kind of gravitate away from I
certainly really really liked it but
those parts I gravitate away from
because I've just not really drawn to
that storyline I think there's more
compelling storylines and one and three
I think two is a great connective tissue
it has a great battle saying that
certainly advances the characters both
geographically and story-wise but for me
three the payoff is where the heart of
it is I think twos the best one without
needing the extended versions I think
that's interesting I think three you
need the extended versions granite
they're long as hell but it tells the
full story you like I think the
emotional boom this is my argument
against area two is that the emotional
room the biggest sense of payoff occurs
in the extended cuts not at the
theatrical and I feel I think that the
theatrical cut of a fellowship is the
strongest of the three so yeah I think
two towers it doesn't need the extended
footage I disagree I think you need
fellowship because you learn more about
Boromir and like he's just not turning
evil for evil sake right like I think
you learn that in the extended version
the two towers oh I see yeah no I think
there's more about characters you learn
more you learn more about the characters
from about Boromir into in the
theatrical cut then like that's right
it's like I think you got some cred
points back for saying yeah well you
know um I could've just called Sean Bean
I wanna hear more I'm not describing Ned
Stark is that lives here why why is the
intro better than the finale um again I
think it really comes down to the the
final version of the film I'm not gonna
disagree that that's seeing you know
waiting that length of time for a payoff
and and the amount the emotional
connectedness that you get and three is
so powerful but for me it literally
comes down to the sort of technical
aspects of it it's just a
more well-rounded piece of cinema threes
incredible and as a fan as someone who's
been with these characters all that time
there's no denying that you're gonna get
a great payoff and it is really strong
but it's very long it you know the the
endings go on for probably 45 minutes
and I could have done a lot for me
that's why I would I would drop it as my
favorite of the three I just think that
there's something about the cohesion and
the the well-paced nature of the first
film yeah I mean I just think that I
think one and three have the same
strengths which is just the interactions
between the characters it's really just
if you prefer the cohesion of seeing
them all get together in the first or if
you prefer the payoff of saying I'm good
to get you know the the payoff of their
stories and the third we're see them
grow and to for me the biggest emotional
for me the biggest emotional oomph of
the trilogy was the last scene at the
docks like from that killer that's
murdered me that seems so yeah I just I
do I have to choose it's it's it's it's
gonna have to be the payoff plus I think
it was the most epic of the battles that
was the most epic of everything else I
would pass this to you I think in
fellowship one of the one of the
strongest one of the strongest moments
in the entire trilogy is the realization
that Frodo has and I'm trying to speak
as someone who didn't plan but I'll do
that but the the realization that Frodo
has that he's not gonna be safe within
the confines of the Fellowship anymore
it's a really important dramatic turn
from there are now we follow the path
that was set as a result of that
decision from into 2 & 3 but I think
that that is one of the most important
moments in the entire trilogy we looks
at these people who are supposed to be
his saviors the ones that are supposed
to protect him and he realizes that they
can
Aragorn cannot resist the power of the
ring and he's not gonna be safe so he
goes out it alone I just think that that
like to end the movie on that note
basically Frodo and Sam going off on
this journey together that you know is
going to be extremely dangerous it's
it's literally the most important
decision in the entire trilogy and I and
that's in the context of that first
movie I don't think you could discount
Elijah woods perform
with Smeagol and acting with a digital
character and that it was just insanely
like breathtaking like the end how great
that was so two towers went sputtering
up the guest he's right but he's doing
all right all right I didn't see them
arguing much against mine I clean up
there Alicia just gonna say the extended
editions the fellowship is 208 minutes
two towers 223 minutes return to the
king two hundred and fifty minutes isn't
that crazy
it's good you do hear they're gonna be
like four hobbits yeah so to wrap up
based on the arguments you did have you
actually very close for me but they did
I think cut you were just like it's the
middle of the story you either one so is
that piracy yeah he's got mother too and
I didn't it's just you just said on the
action where I think they brought some
more specifics to beyond just the action
so again stuck between I don't mean to
keep pointing that you're doing great
Nick no but this is tight it was tougher
for me between you two and I think
you're closing one mean I think you
brought a very reasonable reason why
that moment was so important to the
entire films and so off for that alone
you got it Elijah get to their point my
favorite this is a really interesting
thing this debate because sometimes you
are literally tasked with debating
something that it may not necessarily be
your everything this is very fine or
annoying you'll tell us afterward round
five board died help Elijah's not one of
all is not only one of cinema's all-time
best adult actors but way back when you
were also an a fantastic Hollywood child
actor I still remember your debut in
Back to the Future 2 it was awesome come
on it's an amazing scene but you've been
student you've done amazing work your
whole life but this thank you this
question has actually been asked a lot
so we thought might be fun for you to
get involved okay several people in
Twitter the film Ladd
Sophie Meredith many of you on Twitter
vast what's the best performance by a
kid in a movie so the meaning the actor
has to have been under 16 when they shot
so a kid what's the best performance and
this time I believe who's sorry
yeah Dan's up next there's a lot to
choose from I went to one the I went
with Haley Joel Osment and the sixth
sense is an oscar-nominated performance
and I think more so than almost any kids
role that I can remember the movie
really rested on his shoulders I think
more so even than Bruce Willis because
where the where the emotion in the heart
and the depth of that movie came from
was seeing what this kid is going
through and kind of like realizing along
with Bruce Willis's character the horror
of his everyday life and I kind of wish
that they hadn't done the I see dead
people lying in the trailer because if
you're watching it you don't really know
what's going on with this kid until he
makes that revelation that he sees
ghosts and then he kind of has to play
that whole other level that you don't
see till you go back the second time
which is that he knows that Bruce Willis
boiler alert is a ghost is that
necessary does he he knows I think he
knows that Bruce Willis is a ghost and
so he plays in on a completely different
level of addressing him as if he knows
that no one else can see him and and you
know it's like you can't help me at
first you think he's talking to this
doctor who we can't help him when he
realized it's like no you're just
another ghost she can't do anything for
me and so I think that it's just such a
deep performance and he does it so well
that's why it for me he was a cut above
Nick who are you picking I'm picking
Elijah Wood in Radio Flyer I would have
picked this regardless because Radio
Flyer is awesome Radio Flyer is about
two brothers whose mom marries a drunk
and he's just a dick and this Elijah
Wood plays the older brother who not
only has to take care of his mom he not
only is to take care of his little
brother who gets the more the [ __ ] from
the abuse of debt he's got to become a
man at like 11 years old I was 10 yeah
10 10 years old and step up to this guy
and with him and his dog and his brother
and they take like it's the scariest bad
guy I've ever seen as a movie it's like
the Care Bears book person and this
drunk [ __ ]
Baldwin it was a yes not a Stephen
Baldwin yeah yes and it was like the
scariest bad guy in the world because
it's like nothing scary as a ten year
old kid
then Adam bald Adam well then some
then some drunk [ __ ] who hits kids
and dogs so like and and like not only
that like so like he just stepped up
Charles Bronson style and like they beat
this guy and not only that like they
made a 12 year old in Spring Texas
believe a Radio Flyer could fly it can't
and I got really hurt trying to make it
flat stop it but I had a good family
life so maybe I thought that was the
part of it but ya know we tried to build
the Radio Flyer it did not work that is
so uh yeah I don't think I'm ever spoken
to someone who did that yeah yeah we hit
a mailbox just just messed up the
shoulder these put wings and everything
oh yeah yeah we did you get the on the
lawn mower motor oh yeah no we just like
broke my dad's weed whacker and just try
to get yeah we're like trying to do
magic and like we found something we got
the neighbor's dog because we can have
one oh dude that's amazing yeah so you
have photos of this thing no no cuz my
parents were just like me it's the this
movie is great but did they beat the bad
guy
they beat the bad guy and it's the
scariest bad guy in kids movies Elijah
what's your pick Henry Thomas pick
yourself no I would no way every time
Henry Thomas and et listen that is a
performance that I think will go down as
one of the greats
have you ever seen the audition tape
that he did yes so he was you know he
was filmed it was an improv that he did
with with Steven Spielberg there was no
lines of dialogue and he was just sort
of talking through this notion of you
know meeting the the alien the alien
being taken away from him and his
emotional connection to that character
and there's ability to sort of be that
vulnerable and to sort of access that
deep kind of emotional core is an
extraordinary thing to watch I cry
watching the audition the thing about
the performance in the context of the
film is that it is the emotional center
of the movie if we if we didn't connect
to that character and his love of ET and
and his desire for ET to be safe that
movie wouldn't have worked
it literally relies on that on that
performance it's devastating easily the
most devastating experience I've ever
had watching a movie in a theater in my
life it was my radio work
it is so emotionally raw and it again
it's it's all on Henry shoulders why are
these other two actors suck come on Dan
yeah why do I suck perfectly honest it's
been a very very long time
get out I don't remember a whole lot
about it so I can't speak a lot about
Radio Flyer yeah you'll realize when
they get beat up and then Elijah Wood
became a man at ten years old and you
saw that transformation
you saw his shoulders get broad you saw
instead of Elijah Wood turns into Tom
Hanks right
here's what I'll say Holly Jones that
turned into that Tom Hanks not America's
top man just what I'll say about here's
what I'll say about Henry Thomas versus
Haley Joel Osment I think they're very
similar performance system that the
movie hinges on them I think that I
think Henry Thomas had Steven Spielberg
and Haley Joel Osment had a night
Shyamalan which for me I mean and he and
Henry Thomas also and it's not to
discount is it is a great performance
but he also had that amazing screenplay
he had he had John Williams's music he
had the greatest direct living director
ever you know kind of working in
conjunction with him as movies are
collaborative you know just supported by
some of the but I think it's John
Williams's best score so I think that he
definitely had a lot of support whereas
Haley Joel Osment had the biggest
surprise in movie history but that's
about it as far as like if you're
talking he didn't it didn't have that
John Williams score didn't have those
iconic flying moments it was much more
subdued and I think it was a much more
like it was really just him and Bruce
Willis and I don't think it had as much
emotional support as Henry Thomas very
interesting are you making et and so I
think it's just it's very it's just a
very small performance and it's so it's
amazing to see somebody that young who's
capable of acting so intricately and so
and so small and it's not the big crying
scene it's just these very quiet moments
when you believe that this kid is like a
30 year old inside like a 9 you're
trapped inside like a 9 year olds body
like this is an adult he's gone through
so much more in his life than the most
even adult at
so won't see him like do that and then
also tell me this weird it's so weird
tell me this camp
how dare you even think that either of
you those performances would be better
if a lake how great with those movies be
if Elijah was in it oh god no hey how
great with a lot elijah be any argument
no no oh it is Nick did you think Elijah
was the judge today
no I don't care I'm just you know like
would you be surprised if we didn't have
the same conversation with him not there
we would do it maybe look it's I think
it's the most underrated child's
performance in like movie history like
yeah we talk about these all the time
but we're talking about a kid at 10 year
old who becomes a man on camera and you
see that and it's powerful and they he
stops the bag and you believe that like
you believe a wagon could fly a
twelve-year-old this dummy but other
dummies I'm sure believe this wagon
could fly and you know it's all based on
this performance you know that the
original version of the script before
Richard Donner was a director on the
film the it was more less ambiguous what
happens to Bobby when the plane takes
off Bobby stop wars no I think I think
he didn't live it is ambiguous which in
some ways is better it's an easier pill
to swallow
yeah yeah the postcards right that could
also just be like you just brewed
Michael's gone crazy
you just writes postcards as his brother
I gotta go I'm on your final thought um
that's an interesting point that you
made about the different director and
the set up but I don't think that's
entirely fair I think
but both of those films hinge on I'm not
even going to deal with myself
that's just [ __ ] weird but your
movies a liar both of those films hinge
on the proton that performance and for
me I think the task I mean yes of course
there's like the the sort of emotional
raw aspect of it and hailey Joe Osmond
doesn't have to deal with that as much
as a quiet or more intricate performance
in some ways but hailey Joel Osment
I mean I'm Henry Thomas is also every
kid his task is for everyone who sees
that film to relate to what it means to
be child and what would what would I do
if I was in that same scenario it's the
ultimate fantasy and it feels so real
it's so palpable and again I think it's
because of the way that we connect to
this child his enthusiasm and then him
falling in love with this character and
then ultimately what he ends up going
through with almost losing him makes is
informed by our connection to him
earlier in the film and it's an
extremely powerful thing these are very
hard arguments oh yeah well David McKee
Evans says that Radio Flyer there was
going to be another ending where you
have Bobby as Bobby older is an adult in
an Air Force officers that's a better
ending couple years after $0.06 Haley
Joel Osment was in AI by Steven
Spielberg we're the John Williams school
that's true that's true see right he got
his Spielberg John Williams combo it's
true you really love AI - big big fan of
Mormons but based on your arguments
what's your fare I know we're very very
sorry guys your turn tuned in for some
fun Henry Thomas is a hack
I did say Elijah Wood makes things to
look like [ __ ] you did say that but
you focused a lot more than just him and
we're talking about the performance and
you talked about I dunno we and the end
of together and so I they were honed in
on their performances that's ultimately
why I'm discrediting Elijah's role there
which was fantastic whatever bringing it
down to Henry and Haley you were very
close and I was with you but then I
argument based on he had Shyamalan it
didn't have those score all these things
he didn't have to work with him at that
moment I think that's entirely unfair I
think that's no but I really do I do I
think that's unfair again you begin
but husband well can you discredit a
performance based on the resources
around that actor that's not fair no
that is not fair
well I think he's implying he it was a
harder job we'd say and I should hurt
her job in my rebuttal I should have
said this I would go right back to the
audition scene which had no scripted
dialogue and that that actor pulled
something out of himself that came
purely on his own not in the movie but
what I'm saying is that it proves that
it wasn't just the scenario of be a
fairly close but I gotta based on what
the argument through the moment and
Darren got the slight edge Henry Thomas
is my first choice
you know alright final down here it's
three points stand two points Elijah
Gatwick can't win but we're gonna do it
quickly anyways like remove sucker go to
the point hi this is completely random
let she do this every week slight spin
in a question asked by Jacob boo jelly
boo golly
sorry if I'm surprising your name on
Twitter trolls if you could pick one
movie for the entire world to watch for
return any on loop which movie would you
pick let's how ridiculously hard this
question though it was like that and
this time it's Elijah goes first I think
I do
oh wait no you're right sorry Nick goes
first let me find I'm not gonna you can
change if you like but I know you had
100 Pratt but pick who everyone now I'm
gonna stick with okay go ahead Nick what
are you picking the movies about an
underdog it's about fighting for your
family it's about men's fashion
industrial design it's about Christmas
it's where we learn a German phrase like
shiz and Vista it's where we learn the
ingredients of a Twinkie it's die hard
is die hard with the perfect cast the
perfect movie perfect acting perfect
plot perfect action it's perfect you
can't say a bad thing about die hard
everyone needs to watch die hard if you
want to learn how to write movies watch
die hard because it's got the perfect
like you know a scope and script and
it's tight and it's awesome you'll learn
about acting watch it if you just want
to watch a movie watch that hard if you
wanna learn about Christmas watch die
art do you want to look like watch a
movie about stopping German terrorists
watched I heard if you want to watch a
movie about ripping off a big fortune
500 company watch die hard yeah if you
want to watch a movie with a lot of
climbing through air vents watch die
hard yeah obviously yeah what's your
pick my pick is Groundhog Day this is a
very difficult question I always
struggle with like the ultimate
favorites or even like top 5 lists
because there's just too many choices
the the reason I picked Groundhog Day is
it is an infinitely rewatchable film
when you're considering what is going to
play for infinity for the rest of time
then you've got to pick something that
you can watch over and over again and
find new things constantly be
entertained the the repetition is
literally built into the structure of
the film
which Heights me these are none a those
questions series is made to be replayed
for eternity it's also a perfect film
there's great depth to the film the
ultimate journey that bill Bill Murray
goes on is incredible it's deeply funny
so your movie is just a cruel refill
click on your movies just a cruel
reminder of what this reality has to do
every day like they have to watch the
same movie over and over again and you
want to make a joke yeah you want to
make a movie that shit's in their face
because oh hey the one movie you only
get to watch is what's making fun of you
I want at least entertain these I want
to give them something great very good
point
let's get doing this fight Sam what's
your pick yeah this is so hard it's like
an impossible and impossible III Joe's
The Princess Bride and the main reason
that I chose it is because if you're
forced to watch one movie for eternity I
think it's kind of the opposite of your
choice I think you want variety and and
and thinking about movies The Princess
Bride for me was the one that I could
think of that has kind of the most of
everything if you like comedy it's got
comedy if you like romance it's got
romance if you like drama it has drama
it's got the scary parts with the scream
with screaming eels you know it's got
the funny scenes in the beginning it's
got the sword fighting it's got the
adventure the swash buckling so I went
with Princess Bride for that reason just
because if it's gonna be unrepeated
leader just serve someone the same meal
for eternity it might as well have some
variety do you love [ __ ] doing in
dirt and ego Montoya jokes over and over
and over that's the world you're gonna
run have a world that people going oh I
just for me it's like if you're gonna
have to watch something at least have
something that's got like oh I don't
like this part but I do like romance I
know but I don't like that so that's why
if they put this right it was the most
kind of varied a movie that I could
think there's a lot of variety in that
film why not die hard um why not I mean
just say this die hards a great movie
but it's just like you're gonna you're
gonna go blind and deaf after seeing the
same explosions which easy time which is
what you want to happen in this movie on
repeat like it's it's just it's kind of
OneNote if you watch I love die hard but
you have to watch the same movie it's in
it's in
Elena Oh set over one night I loved
knitting I loved I heart it's one of my
favorite movies at one time but it is a
very claustrophobic movie if that's the
only thing you're ever you're only ever
gonna watch a movie set at night in an
office building forever at least give
you something with some scenery night in
in an office building provides the most
repetitive movie in like it just happens
over and over again yeah what happens
over and over again and so far boy
explain to me how it's repetitive okay
I'm just saying it how many times do
they do the farm boy bit where he
fetches things how many times is in dog
you'll Montoya say the same phrase over
and over and dango I don't know and
dingo maybe patinka Mandy Patinkin maybe
thinking is one of the greatest living
it well yeah yeah you'd been great in
dire machinery dark office building
inside it yeah doesn't look awesome like
80s la doesn't look awesome you don't
see it easily you see it it's under
construction she was naive enough
punishment one building it's the
greatest so I can I can tell me pause
that's all you get
I get why his was a cruel reminder of
the world they're in which is very funny
why not Princess Bride cuz you're
because it's bad I mean because I'm like
me personally I don't want to watch a
children's movie uh whoa whoa whoa whoa
no hold on children's movie it's a movie
that appeals mostly to children all
right I call I will [ __ ] on that I want
to see a movie that appeals to everyone
there is so much humor oh I watch now as
a kid I don't have fine I'll go for my
film which is best for everyone die hard
yeah fun for the whole family would my
family watch it's about Christmas is
that some treacherous pirate oh my god I
love that it's about Christmas it's not
it just happens to be in the background
but I will I will say this it's a great
movie to watch during the Christmas
season though I'm sorry I do call it I
have a Christmas movie I agree I don't
know it feels like some dude was born on
that day had a couple three kings oh
yeah he's the he's the father of our
country East and the clearly the father
of die hard therefore it's the movie
that right Elijah so what do you
comments on it being a cruel reminder
and the variety any any thoughts there I
mean I like the the notion of variety
for but I would say the same thing for
Groundhog Day yeah there's repetition
but the amount of the the variety of
what he explores in the context of the
repetition is what makes the movie fun
it's not literally experience the same
thing every day
he takes that in so many different
directions he spends like I don't know
God knows how many days like a hundred
days trying to kill himself he kills
himself in every way even people kill
themselves you know he he robs he robs a
bank slowly over time learning how to
figure out so be clear this isn't like
clockwork orange' we're not forcing them
to watch this movie over and over write
to watch if they want to watch when they
turn on the TV it's when they turn on
some screen it's the only thing playing
right it's there's some ice cream though
right you don't have to fix in your eyes
and made to watch it clarity for
everybody hey guys you want to watch the
or you could choose to watch neither but
go ahead sorry well either way it's a
pretty cruel world if you're only
watching one movie eternity so I think
any any movie you would ultimately
ty-over I just think it's it's one of
these things that every single time it's
on TV I've seen that movie more than any
other film I've seen and I can always
watch it I always get something out of
it it always makes me laugh and part of
that is the is the repetition what is it
a cruel reminder of the world they're in
oh yeah I don't think so I don't think
it's I don't think it's snowing with you
I would say if somebody said that like
hey guess what you're only gonna watch
one movie for the rest of eternity and
it's Groundhog Day
I would think somewhere there like that
you were in this dystopian hellscape
when you want to watch a movie about
rebellion and and stuff like a movie
that would inspire you to take over
these dicks and like you know me stop
them like the underdog diehards about
the underdog this world needs the
underdog hero more than any yeah but the
Groundhog Day is about a man who's
self-obsessed and bitter and could never
find love and ultimately recognizes
through the course of this journey of
living the same day living hell he
realizes his own faults and changes a
human being and becomes the person that
we all love at the end of the movie
that's that's an incredible
transformative journey that everyone can
relate John McClane did it
mine's nothing mine's not said it winter
or indoors there's colors there's
brushed lightly games there's sunsets
there's romance there's alright Alicia
anything I was gonna say die hard is
rated R so it's edited for TV to make it
PJ the line is changed too often -
yippie ki-yay
melon farmer I didn't say mr. fantasy
romantic comedy-drama just give me a
point based on the lush variety it is
the bed really think it through but that
is probably the most thing you want
about the movie I'd want to watch on
loop but I wouldn't want to watch
anything I might want to watch die hard
but I don't want to make everyone else
watch tired anyway it doesn't matter
what I want any movie loop you'd get yes
so that gives us our final tally for Dan
tutelage is I'm sorry Nick you're gonna
help me the speed round we're going
right to the speed round we test this
with Elijah you're going into the speed
round against Dan the madman Merle game
editor nononono this works again you
each could have 15 seconds I'm gonna ask
the question to both of you no one else
if I'm having trouble I will activate
Alicia and Nick to help me make sure
that we're making the right decision if
you both say the same answer at the same
time it's whoever said at first and then
you pick the other option or another I'm
nervous okay
so Elijah you down by two so you got a
definitely gonna catch up ahead which
copy that has been done many time any
questions
nope it's cue the music it's gonna be
fun these two movies are playing on
cable which one should I watch Jurassic
world or Wayne's World 2 Wayne 2002 if
you're a fan of the show you know that's
very unfortunate for ticket oh really
I've actually not seen it yet but I love
Wiens with Elijah vote for to 15 seconds
go ahead oh why yes let's reset 50
seconds why wait Cyril to go Wayne's
World to kind of spend so long since
I've seen it I was really just going
strictly on the fact that it I don't
want to see the drastic world
um why it's a great follow-up sequel it
isn't it does not shame itself I think
it's it's one of the most successful SNL
comedies ever made okay 15 seconds go
ahead kids born after 1990 you're not
gonna get Wayne's World 2 it's very much
of its time and it's a kind of a
Jurassic Park parody in it
Jurassic world has Dinosaurs it's got
adventure it's got action it's the
second third most popular movie
highest-grossing movie of all time
people love this movie Wayne's World 2
very nice five second rebuttal it's not
I mean look I think that those movies
get discovered over and over and over
again I think Wayne's World is
ubiquitous I think everybody can relate
to the characters they're very funny I'm
gonna activate the panelists I think I
have a call there but Nick who based on
arguments who are you going with Elijah
okay Alicia
Wow I was going to give it to you Dan
but they voted me
[Laughter]
all day we intro to is my favorite
pirate doctor I cross the t's and dot
the lowercase J's yeah the best part is
Jim Morrison and the football phone
crazy name Indian alright number two
back in it for two three I'm happy to
lose those mean all right sorry okay
best movie starring Elijah Wood okay
Oh Fellowship of the Ring best movie
starring Elijah Wood yes ma'am hi store
ok good fellowship fellowship I heard
first 15 seconds on the clock go ahead
discounting what I said previously the
Fellowship of the Ring is the best
loaded it got me into the genre it it
got America into fantasy it's it's so
epic it's such an amazing amazing
amazing movie you've got you shall not
pass you've got all of those characters
those great characters ok yeah if it's
taking that reminder this is speed round
so take a moment gather your thoughts
why his is not why here's his best 15
seconds go angley's masterpiece Kevin
Kline Sigourney Weaver
Joan Allen brilliant cast about the sort
of you know the loss of self in the
1970s from from adults to children where
children became adults and adults were
sort of like regressed sexually you're
in the faculty right five say yes five
second rebuttal said what do you just if
there's something you said you want a
disagreement I just think the Fellowship
of the Ring is so epic and so accessible
to everybody that if you went off base
I'm gonna give you a five second
rebuttal anything else you'd like to
have it has a brilliant score you know
it's based on a great novel it was a
great it's really hard but I think I'm
gonna go to with elijah on my point I'm
gonna actually ask you Alicia what are
you thinking base an argument based on
the arguments I'll go with ice storm
it's tough well if you have picnic just
alright you were close so he you are the
expert so these two movies are in the
bargain bin which one should I buy
big or big hero six a big I heard big
first you're doing big hero six haven't
seen it you're gonna try ready Dan go
big was the movie that that really
launched Tom Hanks it as a force to be
reckoned with it's hilarious
it's got great themes about adulthood
and what it really means to be a kid and
two kids it's like you know be careful
what you wish for because you just might
get it being an adult isn't all it seems
to be it's such a great relatable comedy
to kids to adults it's also deeply
unsetting settling and very creepy yeah
go ahead right but I have to know
yeah it's deeply unsettling it's about a
man it's about a boy he turns into a man
and has basically has a sexual
relationship with a with a woman she in
the end of the the alternate and in the
film regresses does the thing in herself
and goes down to be a child she can
still be with him trip on that I'm not
talking about alternate endings if you
want to be creeped and look at it that
way that's fine I think it's a great
heartwarming movie that I love big hero
six though I mean guys I'm gonna give it
to Dan on that one alright we have two
more dancing the lead here we go boy
I'll take either spelling but tell me
Hollywood's best Elizabeth
Elizabeth Banks
Elizabeth Taylor there it is so I was
thinking Dan you're up um I think
Elizabeth Taylor had a great early
career but she didn't really do much at
the end of it I think Elizabeth Banks is
not only great actress but she's coming
on the scene as a great director to with
pitch perfect so I think that she you
know is contributing not just in acting
but in directing to Elizabeth Taylor
flashes of brilliance all right 15
seconds for Elijah and go Elizabeth
Taylor's an icon I think you know the
early early part of her career she was a
really beautiful sort of Queen an iconic
Queen of cinema but she turned in
extraordinary performances that were
very damaged and and very layered
rebuttal yeah I mean I think Elizabeth
Taylor's legacy is done I think
Elizabeth Banks is just beginning and
it's it's branching out beyond just
acting I'm gonna give you five more
seconds because you didn't really react
what you said anything else you like
that look I think you can say that that
that she's just starting a career but an
icon is an icon she will go down in
history all right I'm gonna activate but
I don't know if I need it I think it's
Elizabeth Taylor Nick I think based on
that argument and going to the final
question of speed round well this is it
are you guys ready for the final one yes
this could probably be its own topic in
itself but I'm gonna ask it anyway great
best movie directed by Alfred Hitchcock
psycho psycho so many rear-window
Wow my two favorite psycho versus
rear-window here it goes 15 seconds in
o'clock Elijah starts at this time go
psycho is taught pitch perfect there
there's not a sort of wasted moment on
screen it's so beautifully constructed
that shower scene and of itself you
could literally make a movie they've
made a documentary about that scene it
took them seven days to shoot that scene
there I think 50 some odd shots time up
Dan 15 seconds the clock rear window
I think psycho eats lunch on that shower
scene a lot the beginnings kind of slow
and the ending is kind of slow rear
window isn't entirely in an apartment
and a courtyard and he somehow makes a
fascinating movie set entirely in one
location with a guy sitting in a chair
doesn't move at all
I love cycle but rear-window second
rebuttal I disagree about the beginning
of the movie being boring I mean she's
she's having an affair she's stolen
money okay that's fair also the first
time in a film that you ever see a
toilet flush Oh Nick based on the
arguments who are you calling it for
okay Alicia Wow all comes down to me I'm
really thinking of playing both your
arguments together I think I got to give
it to Elijah really I think you pointed
out and I'm gonna explain why you both
the things you were saying I mean it's
the same thing it's it's still in a
motel in a small tight quarters we're
doing it the scene alone they're both so
fantastic but probably more iconic than
anything and ruin their four together
I'm giving it to Elijah it's like
fighting myself I'm not even just doing
that to suck-up I think that was really
fair that was good and Wow
how about thank you to Elijah would you
you took it seriously I loved it you
know your stuff I'm so impressed
guys at Elijah Wood on Twitter and
please go to at KU DS movie on Twitter
like how impressed if you're impressed
this guy for showing up then you need to
go check out the movie on VOD and
theaters this Friday at cooties movie
and Elijah would go follow my Twitter
and tell him how good he did because we
thought he did great thank and please
come back
I promise next to him at Merle Dan on
Twitter how was that what this was so
this is so much fun thank you so much
for coming up next to him at Cash Money
it's sorry I did that wrong a dick Fundy
that's fine why did I do that wrong it's
in my book that dick Fundy on Twitter
how fun was this Nick I even know you
lost I got the [ __ ] kicked out of me but
it was
I still feel like I won the PIP answer
so it was a pretty fun answer but he
would get to strike down the drunk you
killed it today Alisha I'm alone
Alicia I'm alone on Twitter thank you so
much how fun was this yeah I like this
chair and I like watching please follow
me on Twitter Michigan managed Signori
tell us how you want who you want to see
in the show what kind of questions you
want on the show all that jazz I'm so
excited that you were here thanks so
much for coming open have you back I
have a great weekend everybody thanks
again every podcast we put on YouTube
comes with this kick-ass graphic listing
all the topics your favorite screen
junkies podcasters are talking about if
you click the topics you can skip around
and choose your own podcast battle
royale go ahead try them all if you
haven't already subscribe to screen
junkies on youtube to join us for future
fights or if you prefer to listen on
itunes click the logo to download an
audio version
[Music]
you